monsieur a déjà accepté tous on peut pas
du tout lui imposer et il ne peut pas
tout accepter c'est la même chose à ma
cliente son quotidien est devenu un
enfer vous a dit que moi je lui faisais
vivre un enfer à l'époque j'ai pas signé
pour que tu ramènes tous tes problèmes à
la maison c'était pas ça le deal
on me demande de me séparer de 58
personnes et la tue moins de 30 moi je
dis si vous agrippez 58 personnes pour
en sauver 500 je vais aux sacrifiés 58
on est à six semaines de l'annoncé du
plan au marché donc je pense que vous
avez aussi quand même pas mal de temps
comment ça se présente
[Musique]
comment on va gérer une contradiction
qui va sauter aux yeux de tout le monde
un nouveau plan d'économies dans un
contexte où l'entreprise et bénéficier
impose une question à laquelle le groupe
ne nous a pas demandé ni de répondre ni
de réfléchir
vous rassurer rapport à votre fils on va
le garder
quelques jours pour comprendre ce qui
s'est passé
et les résultats sont professeurs mais
il a aussi menacé avec un compas supplie
pour après je suis pas ce qui suit pas
ce qui va arriver après j'ai pas
huit jours je mens de plancher la dessus
moi j'ai rendez vous avec le diable sous
général j'ai un retour à faire j'ai rien
autant vous le dire tout de suite je
suis extrêmement déçu par votre manière
de procéder je te dis ça allait être
compliqué tant que le groupe el sol
atteint passe je me livre moi je défends
de l'europe et a su marier avec elle
sonne
je me les gens tout les gens qui
trompait coûte leur coeur se balancer
j'aime les gens qui disent qui se
contredisaient sens dénoncé
et
il ya une stratégie dans cette
entreprise de soutien une stratégie qui
ferait basculer nos collaborateurs à la
précarité on s'y tient quand même
je vais avoir 50 balais quoi je suis
plus d'années derrière moi que devant
moi c'est vrai quoi tiens je viens quoi
alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]